UB-5 provides a sky atmosphere actor that you can place in your scene and then configure
to help simulate a planet's atmosphere.
On this actor you will find a number of different controls that allow you to adjust how the
atmosphere will look and react to lighting, as well as a number of controls that will
allow you to adjust the look without adjusting the physical plausibility.
Let's go ahead and take a look at this inside of the editor now.
So inside of the editor I just have a file, a new level here, and I selected the open
world template because this will be set up with everything that we need.
So if we come over here to lighting and we look for our sky atmosphere, you're going
to see that actor right there.
If we look down we have a number of different parameters that we can adjust here like our
atmosphere height or the effects of multi-scattering.
We can also change how this is transformed so that we can adjust this based on if we
are looking again at the ground or if we are looking at this in space.
There are also a number of other parameters around here, each with their own setting on
how this is going to affect the look and the feel of this atmosphere.
One of the other cool things about this whole system is that it does work with the directional
light and the skylight as well as the exponential height fog.
One pro tip, if you do hit control, alt, and L, you will bring up a quick lighting positioning
tool which will position the directional light in easy to use manner.
Again, that's the directional light selected here.
We just do control, alt, L, and make sure that we rotate around the scene.
And again, this reason that we want to use this is because our sky atmosphere is going
to be slightly different based off of the sun's location and things like that.
So being able to quickly adjust the direction of that directional light to allow us to properly
visualize everything is very important.